Joe germanata is a long time
entrepreneur he is a very famous
daughter musician Lady Gaga remember a
few weeks ago he was in the news for
describing the concurrent condition of
New York as filthy but we want to talk
to him tonight about something different
so many Americans struggle with
addiction we talk about it a lot we
don't talk to enough of them who have
overcome that addiction
Joe germata has been sober for three
years he is celebrating we want to
celebrate with him he joins us now on
set Joe thank you so much for coming on
no thank you I mean this is a happy day
well it's a wonderful day and the I
don't know what the percentage of
Americans were addicted to something a
lot of prescription pills a lot of
alcohol both of which are everywhere how
does it feel to have beaten it
oh it feels tremendous I mean you don't
wake up in the morning the next day you
remember what you did yes right you
don't feel horrible for 24 hours yeah
right you're so much more productive yes
and work and and and your family how did
you do it
I did it cold turkey yeah
um I just decided I you know I had some
open heart surgery and right after I
came back out of the hospital I decided
you know what it's time because I
couldn't drink anyway and I just started
you know doing different things with you
know different types of mocktails yes
and you know it was satisfying
so it wasn't you found it not that hard
after I assume many years of drinking oh
yeah yeah I did well you know what I
don't even like the taste of it anymore
I was a scotch Drinker yeah me too yeah
I try I I drank a river of scotch I'm
sure okay so there's a country music
song about that Whiskey River
um so you hear people I mean I saw a
clip of the governor of California
recently saying from I think a year or
two ago sobriety is overrated we push
people to be sober how was your
experience your three years of sobriety
like
is it overrated no it's no it's not
overrated it's I think there's a trend
now I mean in the in the restaurant in
in my place yeah I'm serving mocktails
and really yeah and there's some really
good imitation gin and uh like one of my
favorite drinks is a it's a Negroni yes
and it's made with
um a fake gin it's called New London gin
light or light gin and then uh Davina
Rosa which is kind of like it's got a
Campari flavor and you mix them together
and you put them on the rocks and you
put a slice of orange on it and it's
a cocktail yeah right and you can sit at
the bar and you feel normal but you
don't do anything embarrassing forget
where you are lose your car keys or wake
up in jail exactly and you don't run
outside to have a cigarette
do you think one of the reasons I so
wanted to talk to you is it's just nice
to see people who've overcome this thing
that can you know we'll absolutely
destroy your life Fair yeah and then
they overcome it and and they like are a
lot happier wouldn't it be it's gonna be
nice if we heard from more people like
you I'm now promoting it all right we're
doing uh the the last Thursday of every
month is mocktail night at Joanne really
yeah this week we're doing on Friday
night we're doing
um
free tastings
of curious elixirs so you go and come in
for dinner and we'll offer you would you
like to try one of these beverages right
and you know the new companies they
they're sponsoring like crazy because I
think that I think the younger
generation now is moving away from
alcohol
right and I mean they've always you know
we're smoking weed right okay but I
think they're moving away from alcohol
now
now some of this stuff is really good I
mean there's a new beer out
it tastes like beer right I'm gonna try
that it used to be a drink of duels and
it was like you know it didn't taste
like anything no it didn't all right
well yeah I quit long ago enough that I
went to club soda never went back but
I'm going to try a fake Manhattan okay
Joe thank you oh thank you
congratulations on three I want a creepy
porn Warrior mug you can have all the
creepy porn lawyer mugs you want put
your fake cocktails in them drink it
with pride all right
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight